starwars I know you're a man we've
talked about this before you're a
massive star late but massive condom
okay it is it's coming Star Wars The
Force awakens yeah do you have a plan
for this he's just gonna casually see in
a movie theater are you gonna because
you're very intense you're gonna do
something crazy well I think I I think I
might I'm gonna try and go to opening
night but I'm gonna want to go to a
midnight screening because everyone
always talks about the midnight
screenings they had on Potter is just
being insane and amazing and like an
amazing atmosphere but obviously I can
go to them so I want to like experience
it somewhere else and this seems like it
would be in a mate like the excitement
around this film is very rare you don't
get that kind of feeling off and around
a movie I think I want to be in the
audience that so it's just like it's
picking a costume now oh yes so if you
go to a midnight show you have to wear a
cast I think so because I feel like
it'll be it you know there's some
crossover between Star Wars fans and
Harry Potter fans I think so like you
should go dressed as Harry Potter
[Applause]
people feel like what the hell let's say
that's a bad possum you don't even look
good yeah that was would you go has it
so well I think I I do almost don't want
to say it in case like cuz I was
thinking about like going as a wookie
but then I cuz it's you know you get
like good coverage from that mask right
but then right I also don't want to say
that in case people just like start and
not everyone's like you have people have
desperate to see you down but like in
case people just like to start randomly
I'm asking wookies rip one outfit Andy